Computer scientists don't normally
write books. We write 12 page papers,
we submit to sit calm.
So it was somewhat of a surprise to me
when I realized I was writing a book.
I'd written several chapters over before
I figured out what was going on and I
think it was a friend of
mine. I said, by the way,
have you noticed you're writing a
book? And I sort of said, oh the,
the short term motivation for this book
was a project to that national science
foundation funded,
which several of us encouraged them to do.
I called the future in
an architecture project.
The research community sort of gets
sucked into the reality of the short term
Internet and everything
that's wrong with it.
So if you look at a lot of the networking
research, it's fairly short term.
We made an argument that at least some
people in the community ought to be
asking, what should the
Internet of 15 years from now,
what's your the Internet of 20
years from now look like? So,
so they did this project called future
and in architecture and pushed a few
people in the community to go do
some longterm research. And I had an,
I had a grant from NSF to sort of look
across all the projects and integrate
what was being learned. And after I'd
been doing that for several years,
I realized that the result
was probably book sized.
But of course the daddy of writing
alternative architecture papers has been
going on in the research community
since 1990 we've had a whole bunch of
proposals for,
well you could have built it like this,
you could have built it like that.
And when I started to go back and
look at all of those proposals,
you realize you can't compare proposals
unless you understand the problem
they're trying to solve.
So a lot of what this book is about
is requirements and people say,
oh, requirements is so boring. I
want to develop this cool technology.
Show me something neat.
But in fact,
when you actually ask what are the
requirements for a successful Internet,
it becomes a very,
very interesting conversation.
So this book is in part
about requirements.
It is in part about alternative ways.
You could have built an Internet,
I think identified 26
alternative proposals that
have been published that I go
through in the book.
Not In painful depth I assure you.
And to a certain extent,
the book is also a personal history
because over the decades since I started
working on the Internet,
which was 1975, um,
my understanding of what problem we were
solving has completely changed. And,
and if I can say just a little
bit about my personal history, I,
in the 1970s we were just trying to
get the protocols to work and it's,
it's important to remember how little we
knew or how little we were sure of back
then. There were people that absolutely
believed you could not write a protocol
specification precise enough.
The two people working only from the
SPEC could actually write interoperable
code.
They simply didn't think you could do it.
And of course today the idea of writing
a standard is sort of like, well,
I'll write one today,
but we didn't know how to do it.
And in fact we spent something like two
years with the TCP standard in which we
alternatively to bugged our code and
debunks the SPEC and to bug the code and
debug the SPEC and it's cause he
had to learn how to write us back.
Then in the 1980s which is when I,
excuse me,
which is when I chaired the
Internet activities board, uh,
we were getting big and the 1980s was the
computer scientist response to getting
big, which is we only know one way to
scale a system or at least back then.
The reflective thing to do
is to make it a hierarchy.
So we made a routing into a hierarchy.
We had the exterior gateway protocol,
which today is BGP.
We had interior gateway protocol.
We made the domain name
system hierarchical.
It used to be a list that John Pasta
maintain. You can download the file.
That didn't work and we had to
organize the standards committee.
We made that hierarchical too.
We created an ITF and created
areas and working groups.
And then in the 1990s aside from the web,
the thing that happened was
it started to get commercial.
And that was a surprising decade.
Uh,
cause we didn't know what the commercial
internet would look like in the 1980s
and the first part of the 1980s the core
of the Internet was the NSF net run by
the National Science Foundation.
And people were playing around with the
idea that there should be little for
profit experiments around the edge.
But when the NSF declared that we're
going to shut down and from that and we
were going to have a commercial core,
we sort of looked around and said, whoa,
we don't know what this is going
to look like. And in fact, BGP,
the border gateway
protocol is interesting.
It's the first protocol I participated
in designing where the specific goal is
to shape industry structure.
And we didn't understand in the 1970s and
eighties that we were shaping industry
structure. But in the 1990s
this became painfully clear.
But my personal experience
in the 1990s was, was,
well,
I'll tell you a specific story.
In the first part of the 1990s I put a
lot of work into quality of service and
we built diff serve an insert
and all this kind of stuff.
And we were trying to get
it deployed in the Internet.
And we went to Cisco and said, put this
stuff in your router. And they said,
we like a customer,
go find me a customer.
So I went to the largest ISP at the time
and I went to the CTO and I said, hey,
there's this cool this sort of stuff and
you ought to put this in your network.
And he said, no, I like clean answers,
but that wasn't the one I want. I said,
why not? And he said, the following,
wonderful sentence, he said,
why should I spend a lot of money?
So Bill Gates can make a lot of money
selling Internet telephony for windows?
And I said,
ah,
the competitive interface, the
specification of the Internet protocol,
which is a cut point in the stack,
is a money insulator.
And you guys know this because you live
above that and you constantly watch ISP
is trying to figure out how to
suck into your value proposition.
They're trying to pull money down
into their layer. And, and I've,
I've talked to some ISP is actually in
Europe, the problem is more substantial.
Uh, you know, I was talking to one
of the ISP is in Europe and uh, and,
and they were trying to figure out how
to suck money out of Google. So that,
and I said, well, why are you trying
to do this? And they said, well,
Google has some. And that was, that
was the depth of their logic. So,
and by the way, then the CTO
said, the following interesting
thing to me, he said,
and by the way, if I did turn on, if I did
put quality of service into my network,
why would I turn it on for anybody but me?
It was 1995 we didn't know to call
it network neutrality back then.
But all of a sudden I
realized there was a problem.
So I realized that the technologists,
we're not in charge of the future of
the Internet. Uh, hired an economist.
I've had a political scientist
that's worked for me.
I've collaborated with lawyers.
I've become painfully multidisciplinary.
This is usually a symptom
that you're over the hill,
but I've been doing it for awhile.
So the book is in large part about
requirements and the requirements are not
just technical. There's a chapter
in there on economic viability.
What does it mean?
How do you think about
designing a protocol or set
of protocol one Kwanna call
in the book of the architecture so that
it is viable as an industry structure?
Uh,
in fact there's some nice
economic theory about this.
There's an economist, one of my favorite
economists is a man named Ronald Coase.
Uh,
and he is famous for having articulate
what's called the theory of the firm and
just said, why do firms exist?
It's really just question.
If you naively believe
your economics 101 class,
which is to say competition disciplines
to the market and you always want to buy
the, the, you want to pick price
and quality for years procurements.
So, so why do you have a big
firm? Why isn't it the firm?
Lots of little from lists that are
constantly competing with each other.
And he made the point that
the process of negotiation,
of finding the price,
finding the quality,
that the negotiation itself was costly.
He called it transaction costs and he
pointed out that of transaction costs are
too high.
Then it's cheaper to build that coal,
that decision into the firm.
And so in some sense planning,
which is what happens
inside a firm competes with
competition to see which one's
more efficient and the interfaces where
you're most likely to see competition
are the ones where the
transaction costs is lowest.
And one of the ways we can make the
transaction costs low is to have a clean
specification on the Internet,
on the interface,
which is to say that protocol
boundaries defined industry boundary.
The reason Internet service providers
look the way they do is the internet
protocol specified the way it was.
And if we had specified a differently,
the industry structure would be different.
Not every economist I've
spoken to said, well, Duh,
but,
but I didn't get this.
There was another famous con
conversation I had with an economist,
and I put this into book too. Um, he,
he doesn't like me to tell this story
and name him because he's worried that
somebody might think the conversation
was actually serious, but he's,
he does work for Google.
And, and he said to me,
the Internet's about routing money.
Robert in packets is a side effect
and you screwed up the money routing
protocols. And I said, I didn't design
any money routing protocols. And he said,
that's what I said.
And whenever we look at disfunction,
for example, the failure of quality
of service and the Internet,
it's not because it doesn't work,
technically it works just fine.
It's because it didn't work economically.
And this was this wonderful
quote from the CTL,
why should I spend money to put this stuff
in so that the apps running on top of
it work better, but the apps
aren't paying me. I said, oh, okay.
So there's a tremendous dislocation there.
So,
so there's a chapter in the
book on economics there.
A couple other areas that we clearly
screwed up in the Internet of very
technical one which is very geeky,
is network management.
And it's really hard to get the
networking community to work on network
management because they want to polish
the data plane. I'm going to optimize,
we are taught to optimize. So I'm going
to get the packets to flow 10% faster.
I'm going to fill that
gigabit link 100% full.
But in the early days of the Internet,
our telephone company friends,
when they weren't busy saying to us, it
won't work. It won't work. It won't work.
Which is what they mostly said,
said if you don't attend a network
management in the very beginning,
you're going to build a system that's
impossible to manage and you should
engineer in every one of your data
plane protocols. That wasn't the word.
They used
management tools and we didn't do that.
So there's a chapter in
the book on management. Um,
if you want your Internet
to be successful,
your protocols have to
last for a long time.
The Internet's been around longer than,
I guess it's not longer than Unix,
but bought longer than most
anything else in the Internet space.
And what,
what is it that you did if you set out
to build a system that would last a long
time? It turns out they're absolutely
conflicting theories in that space.
One theories is requirements change.
And so your architecture has to adapt.
Your system has to change over time
because the requirements will change.
And so flexibility and
adaptability is key to longevity.
But there's a competing competing theory,
which is the thing that makes your
network survive is the stability as a
platform layer and IP.
The Internet that I am concerned with,
you know the stuff up there, the guys
[inaudible] you guys are just apps, right?
You're not the internet, your apps
not to the user. You're the Internet.
Facebook's the Internet. Twitter
see Internet. But you know,
as a network engineer I just moved bites.
Okay.
But the stability of the platform,
the fact that the Ip layer is
not going to change rapidly,
it makes it an inviting place for
innovators to come and sit on top.
And as soon as you have
innovators sitting on top of you,
then they will demand that your platform
survive so that they can survive.
And so you're going to virtuous circle
there in which the platform doesn't
change.
But how do you deal with changing
requirements in that space? Well,
people have argued that that periodically
you just have to throw it out and
start over,
which is one of the reasons
why we encouraged the
national science foundation to
think about a future Internet architecture
project because maybe that time will
come. I had a friend who
was in a different business,
he was in the automobile industry and
he talked to me about the history of
collaboration. I don't know
whether anybody here has
ever worked on a carburetor.
Yeah, okay. It's the Spaghetti
Code of the automobile industry.
If you ever took a carburetor,
a little vacuum tubes and vacuum tubes
on vacuum tubes, but they're so mature,
they were so good that
nobody could displace them.
And they were just
fantastic fuel injection.
Guys were stalking them from the other
side of the street saying this would work
better,
but it wasn't mature.
But what killed carboration was a
sudden dramatic change and requirements
simultaneously. The need to be very fuel
efficient. I remember the fuel embargo.
How many of you were born in the
few of environment? My God. Um,
and the need that's back there. I asked
her I to remember the fuel embargo, right?
And the need to be a very fuel
efficient and cost effective and good
performance.
And when they had to deal with an
emission control and when they had to deal
with all of that once the carboration
guys that couldn't quite do it,
the fuel injection guys took them.
And the only place you can find a
carburetor today is on my lawn mower,
which it could not, it's not
true. My now is electric,
but carburetors held off fuel
injection for like 20, 30 years.
So it's pretty frustrating to live on
the other side of the street stock in the
success story saying, well maybe
they'll stumble and I can take them.
But that was the whole idea behind the,
the sort of episodic replacement theory.
So this is our chapter
in my book on longevity.
I outline 27 competing theories
about how a system can be designed,
so it'll live a long time.
So there's a chapter on economics,
there's a chapter on longevity
as a chapter on management.
Uh,
and as I said,
there's also a chapter
on my personal history,
my,
my journey of discovery.
These various transformative conversations
I've had with economists, uh,
which caused me to hire an economist.
Uh,
there's also a long discussion
in the book on security.
You can't talk about the internet
today without talking about security.
And I confess I've gotten somewhat grumpy
when I go to Washington and,
and people say,
why didn't you think about security from
the very beginning? You got that done.
And the answer is what we did think about
security from the very beginning when
maybe didn't think about it and right.
We should try to think about it.
But the thing you got to
remember is when somebody says,
I want the Internet to be more secure,
or they say,
the current meme is the Internet's broken.
What does that mean?
What does it mean to say the
Internet's broken? I just don't know.
But you have to take that aspirational
word. I want more security.
It's a motherhood where you know,
cheap,
secure and you have to break it
down into actionable elements.
So if you want to talk about security
holistically, you have to sort of say,
well what's a way of breaking it
up into actionable components?
And when you do that,
you realize that different parts of the
ecosystem are responsible for different
parts of the problem.
And I thought I would give you just a
couple of examples in that space because
security is such a hot topic right now.
Remember to me the
Internet is not Facebook.
The Internet is not Google.
The Internet is not Twitter.
The Internet is a general platform that
carries packets and apps can be built on
top of it and you can build any
kind of app you want. You know,
when Tim Burners Lee came along and
defended the web, we all said, oh,
what a fantastic thing. It just
naturally ran on top of our platform.
And then when nobody was
looking, we rent, rent, fixed,
all sorts of things that would work
better. But you know, the illusion was,
you know, it just, it's just
an APP. It just happened.
And when video streaming starts,
we knew we were going to do video.
We were streaming video in the
unit in the 1980s it's just,
it wasn't commercially viable. We knew we
could stream video, we knew we could do,
we just had to wait for enough people to
have broadband and for the cost to come
down, it's a cost issue. You
know there were some curves,
we were watching the curves,
which is how much does it cost Netflix
to mail out a DVD and mail it back and
what is the cost going to be to
stream the stuff over the internet.
And you could see those curves coming
in to come together. Now there was also,
Netflix also had our rent,
this licensing problem. They,
they didn't have the licensing
rights to send the stuff online.
So there's another issue there.
But
we've re engineered a lot of the Internet
again to, to make video streaming work.
And you guys know that you've
put a lot of effort into youtube.
You know how much effort
you've put into it. Um,
Netflix and youtube together are 50% of
all the traffic flowing into most ISP
today.
Okay.
American ESPs and other countries are
suffering the same fatus network as
Netflix shows up,
but you have to go back to security.
When you begin to break
the problem into parts,
you realize that security
is not a dimension along
which you're optimizing and
there's perfection out there.
It doesn't work.
Security is a multidimensional space
in which different objectives actually
compete with each other and different
stakeholders compete with each other and
to build a successfully secure Internet
is to say you have built a compromise in
which all of the actors will, will allow
your solution to survive if you build a,
if you perfect privacy scheme,
this guy from the NSA shows up and says,
can I have a little word with you?
And he does security too.
He calls it national security,
but it's security.
If you build a network
that's completely encrypted,
of course all the people that wanted to
look at what you were doing so that they
could gather demographic
information about you get cranky.
So there are all these
tensions in the system.
But I wanted to say a couple things
about security because it is so important
than um, I broke the problem
in the book into four parts,
which is people who trust each other
or trying to communicate and there's a
third party who is trying to
interfere steel modify block.
Okay? That's the classic
problem of information security.
The second problem is I connect
to you and you attack me.
Okay?
No, I go to a website and it
downloads malware or to, you know,
a download email and it turns out to
be spam or have a malicious attachment.
The third problem is
the mechanisms of the,
the Internet that I'm talking about
are themselves broken and most of the
mechanisms in the
Internet today are broken.
And the fourth one is denial of service
attacks because that's sort of in a
special category. Just so say a few
words about some of these things.
If you look at the,
the basic services of the Internet today,
they all suffer from poor security.
The domain name system is insecure.
The certificate authority
system is insecure.
The routing protocol, BGP is insecurity.
I said, why is this? Why, why,
why, why, why? Um,
the basic vulnerability of the Border
Gateway Protocol is that I can announce
that I'm the best route to someplace.
And if somebody believes me,
some of my traffic comes here.
So I think,
I think a while back there was some Google
traffic that went to Russia and there
was apparently some Nigeria. And who said
it was all my fault. I'm terribly sorry.
Don't blame me. I, this is weird.
We knew this vulnerability existed in
1983 it's documented that we knew the
vulnerability existed in 1983.
So, you know, you could say,
why the rude word,
do we still have the problem if
we knew it existed in 1883 and,
and the answer is not a technical one.
First of all,
there are bitter,
unending debates about what component
that insecurity is actually the most
important to fix.
What is the security vulnerability?
And we really got to deal with,
and if you can't get people
to agree on the requirement,
you're never going to get them
to agree on a solution. Okay?
Some people think without the problem is
his attack on the inner inner exchange
of packets at an exchange of
packets across an exchange.
Some people think it's the
injection of false routing,
disagree about what the thing,
and the second problem is,
the people who suffer are not
the people who would have to pay.
It's another example of why should I
pay a lot of money to save him money?
If Comcast puts a whole lot of money
in to making sure that their routing is
perfect,
did they make any more money?
No. Other people have fewer attacks
on it, but those are other people.
Those other people pay Comcast. No, no.
I've talked to Comcast and they do put
a lot of effort into this because they
want to be good citizens,
but the other problem is
they can't do it alone.
They may be the biggest consumer
ISP in the United States,
but they need other people to do things.
So there's a huge coordination problem.
So if you have a problem where people
can't agree on what the problem really is,
there's what the economist
called a negative externality,
which is I have to spend money so he can
save something and there's a terrible
coordination problem and there's nobody
in charge and the whole essence of the
Internet, there's nobody in charge.
Oh we love it. Whoopee. Okay.
There's nobody in charge. It makes it
really hard to fix these problems. Okay,
so the discussion of economics
relates to the discussion of security.
I want to come back to a couple of other
aspects of security because I've been
thinking about it a lot.
I talked about the classic communications
or information security problems,
which is I want to have a
trusted conversation with
you and somebody is trying
to mess it up.
The classic solution is here come
the cryptographers over the hill,
we're going to encrypt everything
and then everything will be great.
Crypto is not pixie dust.
You can't sprinkle it on a problem
and make the problem go away. I,
I was talking to a counter intelligence
friend of mine and he said,
only amateurs think you have to break
the crypto. We just mess with the keys.
And if you look at the horrible problems
we have today with their certificate
authority system,
which in fact Google is,
is I think leading the charge
to try to make it better.
And the reason why we have horrible
problems with the certificate authority
system,
which have to do with lack of trust,
a lack of understanding of
which actors were trustworthy,
an inability to coordinate a global
system in which people are definitionally
untrustworthy,
uh,
cryptographers tend to say,
well, we'll solve them.
You over there you go solve the key
problem. No, that's where the problem is.
Everybody go over there and solve
the key key management problem.
That is the key issue. Oh God, I said
it. That's the key issue. I'm sorry.
Forgive me.
But there's one other thing I want
to say about information security.
If we teach this in school, we say there
are three elements with sometimes six,
but the most important ones
are confidentiality, integrity,
and availability.
And in the early days of the Internet
we were trying to figure how to do
security.
We,
we were trying to figure out who we could
talk to and the only people we could
find to talk to, this is 1970s
what's the national security agency?
And we went down there and said help
us think through network security.
They only had one concern,
which was disclosure control.
They said, you know, if the spy
steals the stuff it's gone man.
So you got to just have a hundred percent
attention to disclosure control and
what that meant. And by the
way, the integrity on the unit,
it's really easy because what comes out,
it's supposed to be what goes in
and you can usually tell. So so,
but their attitude was, you know,
if you think you've got a data leak,
just turn the network off.
Cause it was not at the time
operationally central to what they do.
So there's a tremendous gravitational
pull to confidentiality or disclosure
control. But there are three elements to
this story. There's disclosure control,
there is integrity,
integrity and there's availability.
It's called the CIA triad,
which is not to be confused with
the Central Intelligence Agency and
availability is an element of security.
You can't solve availability by
sprinkling crypto on it. It doesn't work.
Availability involves using
resources that are trustworthy.
If there's a DNS sending
you to the wrong place,
you have to be able to know
enough to stop using it.
If you're being routed through an
inappropriate part of the internet,
you have to be able to avoid it.
Have,
we do not have in computer science
a general theory of availability.
But if you look at what my
security friends have done,
they have paid a great deal
of attention to disclosure,
control and integrity and they have
absolutely screwed up availability.
I had, I had an interesting
little annoying a fat the
other day in which I was,
uh,
trying to download a update of a
python module and I went to the,
did all the thing, you know, pip
install, whatever the hell your type,
I don't remember what your type, and the
thing came back and it said, uh, the,
the certificate, the signing
certificate for the code is invalid.
It's probably out of date and so
you can't download the module.
I said, what? What's plan B?
There was no plan B.
You can't download the module.
And I'm sure my security friends
thought good day's work. Okay.
We provided with very,
very low probability that almost certainly
there's a was out of date because the
guy's an idiot and you didn't
update it. It's like, you know,
there's 0% chance that it
was actually a malicious,
but they stopped me cold.
Now my attitude is they carried out a
100% successful security related to tackle
me along the dimension of availability
and consumers. I'm sorry,
I hate that word. Users.
What they want to do is get their
job done and we keep saying,
why do people click through
these warning boxes?
Nevermind that the warning boxes are
and explicable that click through them
because they have to get their job done.
And anybody who is designed a security
system which stops the user dead,
it doesn't give them a plan.
B has failed security one on one,
but that's not the way we teach it because
we focus on integrity and disclosure
control. And so we sprinkled crypto on
everything and hope it's done a flame off.
Um, the other thing I wanted
to say about security,
and there's a long chapter about this is
this idea of being attacked.
I can attach to a website, uh,
it sends me malware.
Some of my friends who are
very technical say, yeah,
we really have to focus on the correct
implementation of out of applications.
You know, they too can have
buffer overruns. Oh my God,
don't tell me about another buffer
overrun. The misbehavior you get,
let us say in the web today is not
because of implementation bugs.
It's because of bad design. No, I'm
sorry I won't take back. Not Bad.
Because of deliberate design decisions.
That is to say the way the system
functions is insecure by design.
Now that shouldn't surprise you because
it's very hard to imagine anything as
complicated as the web that doesn't
have risky modalities. I mean,
I can hit somebody over
the head with a hammer.
So the risk of modalities in the web,
or not surprising,
but in fact conscious decisions were taken
to put functionality into the web was
known to be risky.
When the idea of downloading
active code first came up,
every security person I knew was
standing on the sideline saying,
that's the stupidest idea I've ever heard.
You're all going to die.
Why would you download code from
somebody that you don't low?
No know. We tell our kids don't
take cookies from strangers.
Why would you take code from a stranger
and run it on your computer and I,
we actually talked to Nsa about this
and they said inspecting code to see
whether it's malicious as a fool's errand.
The only way you can reliably
have downloads of active
code is that you have a
very clear sense of whether
the senders trustworthy.
You've got to be embedded
in a space of trust,
but if we have risky
modalities in the applications,
you can't expect the
packet layer to fix that.
The application guys have to fix this
and they have to take the responsibility
for understanding how
to balance this feature,
feature rich space that everybody loves.
You know,
what did you get for downloading codes?
My God, you've got Flash, you've got,
you know, animated dancing cats
and it, boy, that's worth it. Um,
against the security risks.
And it is an application problem,
but that's not something that is
understood when you go to Washington.
They say the Internet's broken,
fix it,
and you get some draconian
ideas in Washington,
some of which I hope I
have helped to stamp out.
I had a Senate staffer a while back
say to me, this sounds like nonsense,
but you understand exactly
what he was saying. He said,
why don't packets have license plates?
And I know what he meant.
He meant why isn't there some identifier
in a packet that a third party like a
policeman can look at to
unambiguously understand who sent it.
Okay. Why are all actions on the
Internet accountable to a person?
Well, I mean, there are lots of good
answers to that. One of which is socially,
it's a terrible idea.
Um,
it eliminates any possibility of
anonymous action on the Internet.
And I think there's a space for
anonymous action. Uh, furthermore,
who would issue those
identities in a global world?
Almost certainly sovereign states
would assert their right to issue those
identities.
So what would it mean if I have a
packet that goes by and it says that the
identity of this,
of this,
the sender of this package is verified
by the sovereign state of Iran.
Do I feel better now? You know, so,
but if you don't have an accountable
internet, what do you have?
And there's been very little
attention paid to this. So, um,
although my book is about Internet,
I actually spend a certain amount
of time talking about applications.
And one of the projects we're currently
doing it MIT is to see whether we can
think in a more methodical way about how
to help application designers deal with
this tradeoff between embedding risky
actions because their feature rich and
dealing with the fact you only want to
use them in a context where the people
you're communicating with you trust.
So the book has some
of my personal history.
I talk about stories from
the two thousands as well
as the 19 hundreds and 2000
and ten's a,
there's a chapter on what does
it mean for a network to be,
to meet the needs of society,
chapter on requirements.
And we have one on management as I
said, availability, security, longevity.
And then there was a discussion in
the book of alternative. So why,
and I'm going to stop in a second.
Why are people proposing
alternatives to the Internet?
It actually does what it does pretty well.
What it does is move packets
for machine a to machine B.
The reason they're proposing alternatives
is because they wanted to do something
different,
not because they think it could do
exactly what it does better than it does.
And they want to put more features in
because that's what engineers always want
to do.
They want to add features.
Every people here familiar with the
expression, second system syndrome.
It's when you built up system that sort
of does something pretty well and you
say,
I'm going to build a second one,
it's going to do everything
and they'll fail. Okay. Um,
so what have they talked about putting in?
Well,
one thing that they've
talked about adding isn't,
well you send a packet to a machine,
but most people don't
want to get to a machine.
They want to get to a service that's
on the machine or they want to get some
information on the machine.
So why don't we tell the network what
service you're trying to get to or why
don't we tell the network and what
information you're trying to get through?
Why don't package to have the
names of information in them.
This is an idea that's been
around for a long time.
I think it was first proposed around
1995 by David Cheriton, I think.
Uh, it now goes by the name of information
centric networking and it creates a
really interesting problem. How do you
build a routing protocol that can run,
that can route to a few billion things
as opposed to the Internet today,
which is routing to a few million things.
Uh,
but that's not the real
interesting question.
The interesting question is do you
want to give, do you Mr Google,
do you want to give to the network,
the control over where the network goes
to retrieve a copy for mentioned piece
of information or do you want to
keep that control inside your firm?
Protocol design is actually over industry
structure and balance of power and
there's a lot of discussion this in the
book that adding more features to the
network may in fact be
empowering the wrong person,
whether it's a state that would like to
carry out surveillance or an ISP that
might like to manipulate to get
money across that money insulator.
And uh, the future is not
being defined by technology.
The future is being defined by
these forces, economic forces,
political considerations, contention
in the industrial space. And,
and that's why I'm no longer
running a purely technical group,
but I think I should stop
and take questions from.
I had heard some interesting stories
about how they originally set up protocols
between the big eyes, peas to transfer
packets between each other. Um,
I had heard that the fact that it zero
zero cost between them was an interesting
story. Have you heard that one? Okay.
And in the original structure,
the Internet, little ISP bought
service from big eyes please.
We call that surface trends that other
people might call it long distance.
You pay them and they get you everywhere.
But the ISP is that are at the top half
to interconnect in order to exchange
traffic with each other. Now that's
not getting to the whole Internet.
That's just getting to,
I want to get to your customers
and you want to get to mine.
And there is an apocryphal story
which I think is in the book,
but it's an apocryphal story.
I can't figure out whether it's true
that those first few commercial wide area
Internet providers had to figure out the
business terms of which they were going
to interconnect.
They understood the technical terms on
which they were the business terms of the
issue and they got together and there
was a conversation and at one point,
so the goes, one of the
guys in the room said, oh,
I thought you were going to pay me
money. And it's, it's comforting.
It's complicated when you're having a
conversation with somebody and you're
bargaining and you don't even know
which way the money's going to go.
Friend of mine totally broke a car
dealer. It was just amazing. He,
he wanted to buy a new car and
so he was trading in a used car,
but his mother had recently reached
that age where she can no longer drive.
So they actually, it was trading
at two cars to buy a new car.
And when they worked out the bargain,
he got the car and the dealer had to
give him money and the dealer said,
you just broke my brain. I understand
the math, but if I give you the car,
you're supposed to give me money.
The idea that I'm giving you the car and
I'm giving you by just opted. Totally.
So there's a conversation in which
somebody said, wait a minute,
I thought the money was going to go the
other way. And so as the story goes,
all of a sudden the people in the room
who were technical businessman suddenly
realized that if they let
the lawyers in the room,
there will be a three or negotiation.
And so they stood up and said,
quick before the lawyers get here, I don't
pay you, you don't pay me shake hands.
We interconnect, let's
get outta here. And thus,
so it is said revenue neutral
period was born. Yeah,
that's been disputed
over and over over again.
The latest dispute of course being whether
people like Google and Netflix have
to pay to interconnect with
ISP. And that was, you know,
a fee three years ago was
a serious nasty dispute,
which led to lots of congestion on
the Internet. Some other questions?
Sure. So there's two pieces. One
is when you talk about security,
one of the more recent excitement's at
least for inches around the tls 1.3 right?
It has been the conflict between end
to end security and folks who are,
for instance,
running a data center and need to know
what's going on in their data center or
wanting to based. So
there's, there's end to end,
but then there's also you're
running across my equipment.
I need to know what you're doing or
what's being done so that bad actors can't
come in. Um, and then another piece
of somewhat correlated to this,
I'm curious to your viewpoints is the
tussle that's going on now between network
management and visibility versus it's
just so pervasive encryption versus being
able to manage the networks in a
reasonable fashion and how to um,
manage that discussion.
I don't have definitive answers
to either one of those questions.
The questions are very well formed
when when a data center says,
I want to be able to
see what you're doing,
I want to be able to see what people
are doing or, or some actresses,
I want to be able to
see what you're doing.
That is the fundamental tension.
Who is,
who is responsible for protecting me?
If I'm talking to you and I trust
you and you and I have an encrypted
conversation,
I don't want a third party looking at
what we're doing now am messing up their
system. Well that's an issue
that they have to police.
Do they have to see exactly what I'm
sending to see whether they're messing up
the situation?
If I think you may be attacking me,
then Indian encryption is the whole
wrong idea. I mean, I can explain,
I explained this, uh, by a real world
analogy, if you're sending me letters,
you probably assume that you don't
want somebody opening those letters.
But if you think they're full of anthrax,
then all of a sudden it's, oh, I do want.
So yeah.
And I want them addressed in a hazmat
suit and well trained and they know
exactly how to deal with it.
And that in fact is the tension between
two of the fundamental security goals
that you and I ought to be able to have
a secure conversation if we trust each
other.
And I would be lovely to have a third
party to protect me if I think you're
going to attack me.
And the transition there is not
under the control of a third party.
It should be my decision about whether
I trust you or my decision about whether
I would like a trusted third party
protecting the transaction. Okay.
So I don't want people
unilaterally saying, my job is to,
is to look at everything you're doing.
I want him to say, Hey, I want to,
I want you to do something for you.
I don't trust this person.
Now the question of
network management that's,
that's come up again and
again and again and I'm, I,
I have to say I am reasonably
not sympathetic to the
more extreme arguments that
say I have to be able to see everything
you can do. So at management manage it.
I think in particular what's going on in
the mobile networks today where they're
recoding the video and doing all this
kind of stuff reflects the fact that we
made some bad engineering decisions.
And the,
the incredible capacity we have in the
wireline network is not matched by the
capacity we have. It doesn't,
you know, the wireless network,
they're just capacity constrained.
And so they say we have to
engineer our way out of this.
And because there is this barrier between
what the application guys are prepared
to do and what the network has
to do, the system is, again,
there are these protocol interfaces.
They have to say,
well I have to fix these problems but
I sort of have to fix them on my own.
So I'm going to try to figure out what
you're doing and trans coded and all this
kind of thing. And the wireless guys for
a long time I've been saying, you know,
this layered model sucks
because if we had better integration
between what the application guys did and
what the network did,
then in fact the application guys could
do a better job of helping us manage our
network.
But those are different firms and they
may actually be in competition with each
other. So in the end,
there's a technical problem,
which is a lack of standards to
create cross layer of coordination.
But there's also a tension
between companies that in
fact have Evers interests.
And I don't believe we should sacrifice
and to insecurity as a stop gap there.
We should force people to solve the
problem the right way, which is to say,
let's build new protocols that go
across layer that provides the transfer
performance information across layers.
This woman looks like
she wants to mic back.
I saw her reaching out
for it. Sorry. Yes, yes.
I completely agree that one
shouldn't sacrifice. Yeah.
Hm.
But there's a challenge both in
it going the other direction.
And also if we want to have protocols
communicating between the applications to
the network, then it becomes a
trust but verify kind of challenge.
And what information do you
want to put in? Like with quick,
there was a whole discussion about,
you know,
is it safe to expose a single
bit of information that
can be used to determine a
round trip times,
right?
So there's a challenge
of what information is,
how do you agree on what information is
safe to expose to the network and how
does the network trust that information
from the application when there's not a
potentially cost or economic or other
type of challenge to requesting as much as
you want.
And that's uh,
and that's a very tricky one because
there's, there's no venue in which
we could have that discussion today
if you, if you go to the ITF. Yes.
Although I, ETF is slowly shifting.
They're incredibly uncomfortable
having a conversation.
Whose motivation is relates to,
what am I call the industry structure?
Um,
the,
do you disagree? I think there's
some pieces that are shifting there.
There are pieces that are
shifting. I agree with that, but,
but to have a conversation
in which different actors
with adverse interests get
together and design a protocol is a,
is a very tricky thing and need some very
fair minded people who are sitting in
the middle too basic to try
to arbitrate this thing.
And I don't think we have the structure
to try and make that happen today. Um,
I certainly ran into that. I've run into
that over the years, multiple times.
Uh,
well let's take some other questions.
I saw somebody with a hand over here.
So you mentioned, um, uh,
the insecurity of BGP. Um,
as an example of innocence where you
have a problem where you would need
multiple ISP to adopting
technology to improve something.
But if just one, if you have just
one on board, it doesn't, yeah,
it doesn't get you anywhere and so they
don't want to be the first one. Do you,
so in that case or anything similar,
do you think there's any possibility of
positive progress being made with like
government regulation saying,
Hey,
buy by 2025 you all need to support SPG
p if you're going to operate in America
for instance. Or is
that, is that a dead end?
The question is how much does,
does it help if we do it domestically?
Uh, you know, if,
if traffic from a Google site ends
up in Russia because something,
some packet which was either
erroneous or malicious,
it emerges from Nigeria. You
know, what does, what does,
I'd probably,
the traffic was not originated in that
Google traffic was not originating in the
United States. It was originating get
a Google cache somewhere in Europe.
I don't know where I'm,
on the other hand,
you could say at least we could secure
the domestic experience and maybe when
people go overseas they should understand
that it's going to get worse. I think,
well, let me, let me
give you an analogy. Uh,
when we,
when we came to understand that there
were certain certificate authorities that
were not trustworthy.
I think the Chinese a subsidiary that
was issuing fake certificates saying the
Google's over here in
Facebook's over here, you can't,
you can't wear the sovereign state of
China. We're going to do whatever we want.
You know? And they don't
necessarily say, and by the way,
we don't like it very much,
but the implication there is if
we're going to attack Google,
that's our sovereign, you know,
what are we going to do? Okay.
So what you guys proposed was certificate
transparency and the idea behind
certificate transparency
is you can issue you,
Mr China can issue any
certificates you want,
but you have to put it into the
public log so that anybody can see it.
And our browser won't honor that
certificate unless it's also in the log.
So you can lie, but you can't lie
in private. And we're putting,
using social discipline,
which is actually a better way to try to
discipline a trust space than technical
tools.
Okay.
And some of the most interesting
proposals to deal with BGP do not involve
adding SBG p or something like this.
They involve various kinds of public logs,
which if you choose to put something in,
it will make your world better.
If I check it.
So, and it becomes voluntary,
it's, you know, so, so I think,
I think the way we're moving is probably
not to have continuing fights over
secure BGP, secure origin,
PGP, all that stuff,
but perhaps something
that sits alongside it,
which is a kind of a
log system in which the,
the actors that are
interested in improving their
security have an action they
can take. That is to say it's in
their interest. So we don't have this,
this misaligned interests,
but I think that's the way to
make progress in this space.
And I apologize to the
sounds like trolling,
but when you say public log
to be in blockchain, no,
they look at what Google has done
with certificate transparency.
It is not blockchain. Google is
saying, trust me. Actually they're not.
They're saying trust. Any two
people trust any two organizations,
one of which is Google the, the
certificate of the, the, the,
the certificate transparency log.
You have to write your, your,
your assertion in either the
figure of the room into two logs,
one of which does not belong to one
to one. It belongs to Google. So no,
it doesn't not have to be blockchain.
Blockchain to me in almost
all cases is overkill.
Whether you think it's a good idea at all.
To me blockchain is a,
is an example of somebody
trying to design,
I was talking about applications
that have risky modalities.
To me blockchain is an example of
somebody trying to build a restricted
application functionality
into a system in which
nobody has to trust anybody.
You know, I can do look
at the basics. It's,
it's like you're going to pay me money
right now and you and I have to have no
trust in each other whatsoever
because we trust the mechanism.
It's a purely technical solution to
creating a trustworthy transaction into
trust free space. And the real
world doesn't usually work that way.
You know,
the,
the world actually works much more
efficiently because it's willing to make a
few trust assumptions. And I dunno
what China thinks about Google,
but most people are willing
to believe that the,
that the certificate transparency
log that Google runs,
which in fact is blockchain in the
sense that it's forward change.
You can't go back and change things.
It's not a literally a block chain,
but it's a for retaining protocol
and it's done. The, by the way,
the reason Google did that
is to protect themselves.
That is to say somebody could come to
Google with a court order or a, or a,
or a small nuke and say,
I want you to go in and change that entry.
They can't do it in a way that can't
be seen, that can't fake an entry,
even if they're being coerced.
So the structure of the thing
protects them from coercion.
And I think that was actually more
important in engineering decision then.
Then Google is not trustworthy,
but that,
but that makes them more trustworthy
because look, they say, you know,
we can't even be coerced into changing
the century. So it's blockchain ish,
but it's certainly not.
It's certainly not a zero trust blog team.
Leeza.